for somebody who is interested in
learning more about how performance
works and how it might benefit their
life do something that totally scares
you every day and then get to know
yourself you know point the finger back
who am I how do I operate what works
what doesn't what I like what don't I
like What's My Heart of Darkness create
your own film World get to know your
character I can tell you right now what
mine is it's that I'm not special so
every Behavior lends itself to the
pursuit of never having to face that
Heart of Darkness if that's the case
let's look at my training where am I
stressing myself physically and
emotionally and then how do I be
creative in finding ways to progress
and then you create a structure out of
that and then you analyze with your kind
of science brain and that helps you
achieve